NASA's Terra Modi's satellite is
orbiting 450 miles above the North
Atlantic 150 miles off the coast of
Florida over the Bahamas the satellite
photographs coastal clouds when it
captures something meteorologists find
strange
when they analyze the image they spot a
series of hexagon shaped clouds
this satellite imagery is really bizarre
dat the hexagonal shapes of the cloud
formation you don't typically see
straight edges with clouds most of the
time clouds are random in their
distribution the hexagons range in size
from 20 to 55 miles across clouds like
this would be intriguing anywhere but
the location of these makes them
fascinating this is the western tip of
the Bermuda Triangle
this notorious area of the North
Atlantic between Bermuda Florida and
Puerto Rico is the scene of many
reported disappearances of aircraft
ships and people so how are these
strange hexagonal clouds connected with
the disappearance of ships and planes
the answer lies four and a half thousand
miles away in another satellite image
taken over the turbulent North Sea off
the coast of the United Kingdom more
hexagons spreading over 35,000 square
miles roughly the size of Ireland this
image was captured by the satellite n
VSAT MP Sat carries radar equipment that
can see through cloud to what's
happening below
with today's radar we can actually
detect things that previous to that we
simply couldn't have seen a radar image
taken at the same time reveals sea level
winds of almost a hundred miles an hour
that's the top of the Beaufort scale
powerful enough to generate waves over
45 feet high I would not want to be in a
boat underneath something like that
scientists believe the powerful winds
recorded by radar in the North Sea also
exist below the hexagonal clouds over
the Bahamas and meteorologist Randy
Cerveny thinks they're connected to a
terrifying atmospheric phenomenon these
types of hexagonal shapes of the ocean
are in essence air bombs they're formed
five what are called microburst air
blasts of air that come down out of the
bottom of the clouds and then hit the
ocean and then create waves that can
sometimes be massive in size as they
start to interact with each other the
blast from an air bomb or microburst
spreads outwards at speeds of up to 170
miles per hour more than sufficient to
tear down trees on land or flip ships on
water
if professor Cerveny is right and these
strange hexagons are the signature of
deadly air bombs then this satellite
image could provide an explanation for
the disappearance of ships like the SS
Cyclops it could explain how the lost
squadron of 45 was knocked out of the
sky it could solve the riddle of the
Bermuda Triangle
now satellite analysts are scanning the
triangle for further signs of these
weird clouds
we can trigger an alarm that will tell
the forecasters thats a microburst has
been created it's no exaggeration to say
that satellites are actually lifesavers